silver state schools credit union is
back to show us how they've helped the
community in 2020 because we've needed
it
and how they continue to plan or the how
they can plan to continue to help
in the new year let's check this out
always great to see you and i see you
guys have a new wall that looks good we
do we you know we've got our
obviously our logo and our name but uh
we also have our purpose statement which
is prioritizing people over profit
that's awesome you guys do so much for
the community and it helps me with the
mouthful
silver state schools credit union yep
here to help all the time so
definitely so how are you guys helping
the community during this crazy year and
then what are your plans for 2021 to
continue helping
yeah i'm glad you asked i mean we're
always looking for opportunities to
support our local community
and in 2020 we have the opportunity to
make a huge impact with over eighty
thousand dollars in
annual renewable scholarships uh for
nevada high school seniors
and on top of that as far as the
pandemics concerned
we've also born the cost of over 60
million dollars in mortgage forbearances
and consumer loan deferrals
for families that have been impacted by
the pandemic the credit union is also in
the process of releasing our 2021 happy
times calendar
in the next few weeks and winners and
their teachers will be awarded actually
100
uh prize and profits from the calendar
sales um will be contributed to the
people over profit
uh charitable foundation that we
established in 2020.
happy times that's exactly what we need
to hear right now it is it's a and it
and the calendar really does put a smile
on people's face and so
so and you asked about 2021 so we expect
additional challenges to
present themselves obviously with the
pandemic um actually raging
right now and and silver state schools
credit union will have all hands on deck
looking for opportunities to serve and
support the community well
it's obviously the holiday time and it's
so busy people are out
shopping or online shopping how can we
protect our finances what are your
what's your advice on that
and there's a few ways you can protect
yourself and and your finances this
season um
if you plan to travel out of town uh for
instance notify your financial
institution of your travel plans and
prevent
decline transactions because that
actually happens more often
um than people think is you know uh they
don't know that you're traveling and and
so they
they think it's fraudulent and so it's
it's out of an abundance of caution and
so
um and if you're making a charitable
donation this year
make sure you research the charity and
and whatever you do
don't watch out for unsolicited emails
and links
uh you don't want to click on any links
or attachments that are unfamiliar
sources
or or a number that you don't recognize
and so
um and then i wanted to mention at the
beginning of october silver state
schools credit union also
uh introduced a new card control
application called
card force and and i always like to talk
about that because members can actually
manage their credit union
debit and or credit card accounts by
reviewing real-time alerts uh when their
card is used
listen may the force be with us right
yes exactly
now is there any special promotions you
want to tell our viewers about
yep uh all the way through the end of
december we still have our what we call
our great auto refinance program it's
called the abc
uh loan uh for a better car and that
goes through the end of december and
that's an excellent opportunity
for current and potential members to
save money so what matters most this
this year this season with a 90 days to
first payment option
and also the opportunity to potentially
reduce your existing
auto loan interest rates always doing
such great work for the community give
silver state schools credit union a call
at 702-733-8820 or just find them online
at silverstatecu.com
forward slash abc loan we'll be right
back here on las vegas now